Actor, comedian, and commercial pitchman Paul
Hogan won a Golden Globe and an Oscar nomination
for his role in the extremely popular 1986
comedy "Crocodile" Dundee.
The movie earned $328 million worldwide and
its sequel brought in another $239 million,
making Hogan one of the biggest stars of the
'80s...but he never quite made a name for
himself internationally outside of playing
the role that made him famous.
So, whatever happened to Crocodile Dundee?
Marriage problems
Hogan was married to his first wife Noelene
for nearly 30 years, but while Hogan was making
Crocodile Dundee, he fell in love with his
onscreen romantic interest, American actress
Linda Kozlowski.
He divorced Noelene, married Kozlowski in
1990, and the pair had a son together, expanding
a family that already included Hogan's five
children with his first wife.
Their marriage lasted for well over 20 years,
but it eventually ended when Kozlowski filed
for divorce in 2013, citing that "they grew
apart," but also because she was tired of
living in her husband's shadow.
Who knew that Hogan even cast a shadow in
2013?
He declined huge movies
Some actors have the luxury of making only
the movies and shows they really want to make,
and Hogan thought that he fit that description.
Dating back to his early days as a writer
and star of his own TV show, Hogan liked to
have creative control, and he rejected a number
of projects that could have advanced his career.
He turned down the lead role in Ghost to make
his own movie about a ghost, Almost an Angel.
Ghost cast Patrick Swayze and was a smash
hit, but you probably haven't even heard of
what Hogan ended up doing.
"Paul Hogan is… almost an Angel."
For a guy with Academy Award nominations,
a major movie franchise, and an Oscars-hosting
stint under his belt, Hogan has shockingly
few credits to his name.
Apart from his Crocodile Dundee films and
Almost an Angel, he's starred in just four
other feature films: Lightning Jack, Flipper,
Strange Bedfellows, and Charlie & Boots.
The last two weren't even commercially released
in the United States.
By 1989, America had already moved on to fellow
Australian Yahoo Serious anyhow.
"Now, Australia's colossal comedy hit, starring
its newest comedy hero, comes to the states!"
And we all saw how that turned out just a
few years later.
"I know those words, but that sign makes no
sense."
Entrepreneur
Back in 1993, crowdfunding wasn't really a
thing, so Hogan created created the first-ever
film trust to fund his cowboy comedy Lightning
Jack and placed it on the Australian Stock
Exchange.
The trust raised $35 million Australian dollars,
and investors were to see a payout after seven
years.
However, there probably weren't too many profits
to go around: Lightning Jack was a box office
bomb, despite it being one of Cuba Gooding
Jr.'s earliest big-screen roles, earning back
about half of the money it had raised.
As scheduled, the Lightning Jack Film Trust
was delisted from the Australian Stock Exchange
in 2001, but Hogan was decades ahead of his
time in his approach to funding films.
Take that, Zach Braff.
Crocodile Dundthree
Long after the character's popularity peaked
in the late '80s, Hogan brought back Crocodile
Dundee one more time for 2001's Crocodile
Dundee in Los Angeles.
It earned just $25 million in the US, and
more surprisingly, only $7 million in Hogan's
native Australia.
Critics hated it, and it later earned a Razzie
Award nomination for Worst Remake or Sequel.
Matthew Berry, one of the film's writers,
told the podcast How Did This Get Made? that
he and writing partner Eric Abrams pitched
their idea for a third Dundee film to Hogan.
He approved it, and the writers came back
three months later with a screenplay.
And that's when things got...weird.
"Basically he then rewrites pretty much the
entire script.
He throws a couple of new things in there."
While the general plot was unchanged, Hogan
claimed he'd rewrote so much that he should
be the only credited screenwriter, and subsequently,
the only writer who would receive residuals.
The Writer's Guild wound up ruling in favor
of the original writers, and Hogan protested
the decision.
If Hogan ever wants to bring the character
back to the screen, he needs to offer Berry
and Abrams the option to write the script.
How does Crocodile Dundee Goes to Hell sound?
Tax trouble
After his name came up in a 2005 government
investigation into offshore tax havens, Hogan
battled Australia over millions in allegedly
unpaid taxes.
A closer look at the actor's finances found
evidence that he hadn't paid taxes on more
than $37 million earned, dating back to 1986.
Although Hogan lived in the U.S. and paid
American taxes during much of that time, he
was still considered an Australian citizen,
and was not only their tourism spokesperson,
but 1985's Australian of the Year.
"Come and say good day and I'll slip an extra
shrimp on the barbie for ya."
In 2010, Hogan left his home in the U.S. to
attend his mother's funeral in Sydney, Australia,
where tax officials served him with papers
preventing him from leaving the country until
his case could be resolved.
The matter was settled after two years of
mediation under confidential terms.
Which probably involved a didgeridoo and a
couple of koalas.
He took his show on the road
In 2013, Hogan returned to performing and
writing with a comical, biographical one-man
show in which he talked about his colorful
life.
"So how much of this new show have you prepared?
It's touring in November, December, where
are you at?"
"Oh it's easy.
I've been working on it for like forty years."
An Evening with Hoges was a huge success,
selling out dates around Australia.
He brought back the tour for another string
of performances, Hoges Live, in 2015.
Retired
By the time Hogan found international success
with Crocodile Dundee in 1986, he was 47 years
old — a late bloomer to say the least.
He'd been working in entertainment for well
over a decade at that point.
He's since joked that he works less because
he's instituted a "self-imposed exile."
Whatever he wants to call it, Hogan is now
pushing 80 — a perfectly reasonable time
to slow down a bit.
We'll always have his glowing endorsement
of Australia.
"Ah, pleased to meet you."
"It's okay, he's Australian."
"Maybe I better go there someday."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!